هي مخاوف بطبيعه ما اعلنه حزب الله في
بيانه بانه سيقوم برد قوي على مساله
اغتيال القيادي في حركه حماس الشيخ صالح
العاروري هذا الرد لا يعرف طبيعته بعد متى
سيكون وكيف سيكون والى اي مدى سيصل من
جانب حزب الله لكن الواضح بان حزب الله
سيكون له عمليا موقف واضح هذا اليوم من
خلال ما سيقوله الامين العام لحزب الله
حسن نصر الله في احتفال يقام في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه هذا المساء حزب الله عمليا كان
شن خلال الساعات الماضيه اربع 10 عمليات
ولكن لم يعلن في بيانها باي من هذه
العمليات بانها كانت ردا على اغتيال
العاروري حزب الله كان يقوم بعملياته
وتقوم اسرائيل بالرد في مناطق في جنوب
لبنان لكن هذه المره الاولى التي يعتبر
فيها حزب الله بان الاغتيال الذي وقع في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه هو مساله في غايه
الخطوره كل العمليات التي كانت تقوم بها
اسرائيل كانت على القرى في جنوب لبنان
تخطت بعض هذه القواعد باتجاه مناطق اعمق
صعدت من عمليات استخدام الطيران لكنها
المره الاولى التي تقوم بال هذه العمليه
داخل الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت التي تعد
معقل رئيسي لحزب الله هذه ال هذا الامر
يعتبره حزب الله تخط للقواعد السائده
لبنان يعتبره تخط للسياده اللبنانيه وهو
سيتقدم بشكوى الى مجلس الامن وعبر عن ذلك
رئيس الحكومه نجيب مقاطي الذي اعتبر بان
اسرائيل تريد نقل المواجهه من غزه وازمتها
الى لبنان حزب الله كان في عام
2019 قد رد
على على مساله امنيه كانت قامت بها
اسرائيل من خلال مسيرتين سقطتا في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه دون تحقيق اهدافه ما اعتبرها
حينها حزب الله بانها كانت ل محاوله
اغتيال احد عناصره او كوادره لكنه رد في
ذلك الحين عبر جنوب لبنان
بمهاجمه اهداف في منطقه
افيفيم وهي المنطقه المتاخمه لمارون الراس
حزب الله لديه حساسيه عاليه من هذه
العمليات التي تطال عمق مناطقه ال الرئيس
ويعتبر في ان ذلك يتطلب رد وهذا الرد ربما
يؤدي الى العوده الى القواعد التي كانت
سائده بعدم وقوع اي اغتيالات وهي لم تقع
منذ عام 2006 منذ ما بعد حرب تموز يوليو
عام 2006 وايضا يعتبر بانه لا يرغب بتحويل
لبنان الى ساحه اغتيالات ليس فقط لحماس
وانما لكوادر التنظيمات الفلسطينيه او حتى
لكوادر هو في كل لبنان وبالتالي يعتب هذا
الرد هو ايضا دفاع عن هذه القاعده التي لا
يجب التفريط فيها في هذه المرحله التي
ربما كل القوى الفلسطينيه وحزب الله كانت
اخذتها بعين الاعتبار خلال الفترات
الماضيه خصوصا وان حزب الله كان يتحدث
باستمرار عن رد قوي في حال حصولها في
لبنان